We have a voicemail number and that number
is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here's a voicemail from someone who I sympathize
with in terms of the feeling that they have.
But we always want to remain realistic and
pragmatic.
Take a listen.
Hey, David, this is Mike from Indiana.
I just got a comment.
They should do that.
Use the 25th Amendment would kick.
Of office, and he shook out Dracula to prison.
Right.
Guts my opinion.
He's responsible for the murder of all these
cases of coronavirus, that's all.
Yeah.
So, listen, I understand the frustration in
our country.
Even if you're removed from the presidency
for being unfit, you don't go to elect directly
to prison.
We need indictments.
We have due process here in this country.
All that stuff.
But I get the frustration and there's no doubt
that Trump is not fit to serve.
But here's the reality we all just need to
come to.
OK.
The opportunity to remove Trump comes in six
and a half months and it will be when we vote
in November.
Everybody's got to vote in November.
So it's time for everybody.
It's time for the Green Party, centrist Democrats,
disaffected Republicans, former Bernie supporter.
Everybody's got to come together because impeachment
is not going to remove him.
Twenty twenty.
Fifth Amendment is not going to remove him.
None of these mechanisms are going to work.
We have been saying it since before the results
of the Mueller probe were published.
Nothing has changed.
We are down to six and a half months and it's
crazy because four for three years we've been
saying the same thing.
He deserves to be removed, but he's not going
to.
And the opportunity will be November of 2020.
We said it two years ago.
We said it one year ago.
We are six and a half months away.
It's mid-April.
Early November is when this happens.
That's the way to do it.
Get your frustration out by voting in November.
Ideally via absentee ballot.
We don't know exactly what's going to happen.
A lot of those decisions will be made at the
state level.
And I'll talk about that on the Friday show
during audience questions.
But that is the most important thing that
we can do because these other mechanisms aren't
going to work.
We're all seeing front and center the disaster
through his dealing of corrupt with coronavirus
that this presidency has been.
It should be the last straw.
The straw that broke the camel's back.
Whatever metaphor you want to use.
And we've got to vote in November.
That's it.
The left has to come together.
We can't be divided.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Florida's totally smurf.
Like a governor, Ron DeSantis has determined
that professional wrestling is an essential
business is an essential business.
During the pandemic, a court has thrown out
Donald Trump's rollbacks of school nutrition
rules.
You may not even have known that he was doing
this.
A court has thrown it out.
And we have more and more people protesting
in their cars because they can't safely march
in their streets.
I will talk about that and so much more.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Packman dot com or a patron
at Patry on dot com slash David Pakman show.
We've got the show.
We've got the bonus show.
And then later today, most evenings we have
the livestream of the White House Corona virus
press briefing.
Join me for one.
Join me for all of that.
I'll see you then.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.